when you joined the task force do you go
back and look at some of the cases
they've already been studying for
example tic tac and gimbal absolutely in
fact uh i i've studied uh all of those
in great detail uh and actually i'm
doing a new analysis uh since i've
retired with the data that's available
to the public on the gimbal video and uh
it's it's clear from the gimbal video
that there are things in that that
are not typical of of aviation vehicles
do you think you understand the physics
of how those things fly what's probably
no i don't think i understand the
physics of it but what i do understand
is they're flying in a way that we don't
um there there's something going on
there that appears to be propellantless
propulsion uh because we don't see
exhaust plumes we don't see turbulence
wakes and the other thing is we don't
see
matter around them change as it passes
through the different media
like the puerto rico video for example
the thing flies right into the water
with no splash no wake and it's moving
about 75 calculated 74 miles per hour
and to move a thing that i estimate to
be about the size of a basketball 74
miles per hour underwater under salt
water would take the power of a jet of
two lear jet engines
to do that and maintain it you would see
the water churning if there was that
going on but it doesn't
let me ask you this um
we hear complaint
complaints about these vizio videos are
fuzzy why don't we have clear videos we
must have great sensors and cameras the
military has them why do we always get
this fuzzy stuff is there a
uh if a reason that some of these things
might be fuzzy a field around them or
something like that that would uh would
interfere with the ability to get a
really clear close photo well so what's
wrong with the gimbal video for example
uh so the app clear which is what the
device is on the f-18 that was used to
capture that is an amazing uh piece of
equipment built by raytheon
and it captures really clear videos of
f-18s f-15s you know
sukhoi 22s you name it
it's it's captured great video but uh
when you look at the whatever the object
is in the gimbal video
it's completely saturated in temperature
meaning it's really hot and so it
saturates the camera so you can't see
any details about its shape
and around it even though it's really
hot around it is a region of really cold
air
and that makes no sense either you go
from really hot to really cold and then
you have a bubble uh zone that you're
now at ambient temperature like the
clouds and this suggests that
something is uh creating sort of a i
don't know if it's a field propulsion if
it's uh just because it's so hot it's
creating this turbulent region around it
but that doesn't make any sense
physically now i will tell you that
from recent calculations i've done
if this device
whatever this object is is further away
than eight kilometers then it has to be
at the temperature of the melting point
of aluminum
and if it's further than 50 kilometers
it's at the melting point of steel
that's how hot it would have to be to
show up this way in this sensor so it's
not a jet that's 50 miles away and we're
getting glare off of it it's that's not
what it is can they be are there cases
basically they're they're there but
they're they're not you can't see it
with your eye or with the camera well uh
george i think that's actually happened
to me personally uh where we've seen
things in the infrared cameras out at
skinwalker ranch all around us and then
when we move the camera down they're not
there visibly and that to me is kind of
startling and bizarre uh and there have
been many
uh incidences where and i think the
puerto rico one is is a case where i
don't think people saw it because this
thing looks like it flies right between
the cars on the road nobody reacts to it
but it makes me wonder if you can only
see it in the infrared and not invisible